after Tom met Taylor's parents in
Nashville last week they hopped on a
private plane to meet his mom Diana now
it really looks something like out of a
rom-com movie or that Taylor Swift music
video this is definitely something new
for Tom who's been pretty private with
his personal life up until right now the
two flew to Suffolk on the east coast of
England for the family get-together take
totally dressed for the chilly English
weather but her strappy sandals for a
rocky beach walk weren't exactly
practical so she switched to a pair of
sensible rubber boots the Brits call
wellies Keith Urban and Nicole Kidman
spent their 10th anniversary apart
Keith performed in the Boston area
sharing with the crowd a photo of the
day they met and some wedding pets
packed the show he was heading to where
his wife was shooting a movie
new couple alert Chris Evans and Jenny
slate made it official at the premiere
of her new film secret life of pets
what's so great about having him out for
a special day like then I mean for me I
haven't really had this very large
premiere before so it's nice having
someone who sort of knows how it goes
and also honestly we're just like both
two teenagers from Massachusetts so it
kind of feels like I got my dream
seventh grade boyfriend also at the
premiere Kevin Hart was solo without
fiancee and eco Parrish who was having a
bachelorette party in Punta Cana in the
Dominican Republic the groom-to-be turns
37 July 6 you could tell her right now
if you need some big birthday plans you
you that's it see that look at those
brownie points that's the biggest
birthday gift away nothing else the two
will be walking down the aisle this
summer on August 8th oh come on Kevin's
playing a little bit there but he really
is just a big old romantic softy I'm
calling him out